nous sommes le vendredi 8 mars aux
alentours de 18 heures les policiers
sont appelés sur une intervention à
l'espace saint quentin une quarantaine
de jeunes ils sèment le trouble
une policière et blessé et ce n'est pas
la première fois on n'est pas sur un
phénomène de bande
comme on a pu connaître il ya quelques
années en arrière sur le parvis de la
défense
on est sur un rassemblement de jeunes
qui viennent parce que la structure
aussi prête vous avez des commerces vous
avez vous pouvez avoir des attractions
ludiques tels que le tel que le cinéma
et les faits deux bombes de demande peut
s'interpréter du fait comme ils vont se
retrouver groupés et bien on peut
arriver sur des débordements mais ça
reste ponctuel le malaise est en tout
cas en train de s'installer entre d'une
part un centre commercial sqy ouest vidé
de ses magasins et d'autre part un
espace saint quentin qui attire les
squatteurs certains magasins ont reçu la
consigne de leur direction de fermer
boutique au moindre problème
d'autres commerçants ne se sentent plus
en sécurité
je n'étais jamais tranquille le soir
quand j'allais chercher ma voiture au
parking
je demandais aux vigiles de
m'accompagner et j'ai même pensé à
déménager depuis l'agression les
patrouilles de police ont été renforcées
des vigiles recrutés de ségou devrait
apparaître dans les prochains jours des
moyens humains et départ cent quarante
caméras de vidéosurveillance selon la
mairie de montigny entre 2011 et 2012
la délinquance au centre commercial
aurait baissé de 22%
c'est vrai que c'est que c'est pas
normal non plus d'avoir toujours à gérer
des personnes qui sont là pour nuire
donc tout simplement c'est au
propriétaire du centre de
pouvoir assurer une certaine sécurité
aidées en cela par la police nationale
et aussi par la police municipale si
besoin se faisait sentir
le directeur de l'espace saint quentin
hervé de lyon doit rencontrer ce
vendredi le commissaire de guyancourt
pour faire un point sur l'enquêté
les deux jeunes agresseurs âgés de 13 et
14 ans n'ont pas encore été traduit
devant la justice